from the atlantic to the black sea
a massive military exercise
nato launching itself against an
imaginary threat
testing its readiness while its top
brass grappled with a very real crisis
over belarus
nato secretary general jen stoltenberg
condemned the forced diversion of the
ryanair passenger plane
what happened is absolutely unacceptable
and uh we have seen also a pattern of
russian behavior over the last years
but did he agree with the british
government that russia was most likely
involved too
i think they are very right to say that
because we know the very close
relationship
between russia and belarus and therefore
it's hard to believe that
the regime in minsk could do something
like this
without any kind of coordination with
with russia
[Applause]
the comments weren't eased tensions in
russia's backyard
as thousands of nato troops exercise in
romania
and navies drill in the black sea
in the atlantic britain's new aircraft
carrier hms queen elizabeth
is leading the exercise the aim of
operation
steadfast defender is to test nato's
ability
to deter threats and defend itself but
the exercise is being overshadowed by
this challenge from belarus
and possibly russia to what the alliance
stands for
there could be more friction with russia
and its allies as the queen elizabeth
strike group
heads east from this deck in the
mediterranean
british and american jets will be
patrolling the black sea
monitoring russian activity we'll always
be keeping an eye on it uh
horizon scanning is is a sort of daily
um activity for us here just
understanding what the threats are
um and we have to be on our guard i've
said
to a number of uh people today
miscalculation is something we have to
be really wary of
britain's first sea lord says russia
needs watching closely
russia is is looking to to demonstrate
what it might be able to do to us russia
is trying to demonstrate
where it may be able to threaten
nato interests and values
it's the queen elizabeth's first
operational deployment
a challenging debut for her and her crew
as they and their nine vessel strike
group
embark on a seven month voyage dominic
waghorn sky news
on hms queen elizabeth